well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what is
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the sun
pepper creera and harry cole welcome to
both of you
as ever though let's take a full look
first of all at the front pages starting
with the financial times which reports
that the prime minister is facing
cabinet deadlock over whether to bring
in any tighter covert restrictions in
time for christmas
the eye reports that ministers demanded
more data on the impact of the omicron
variant during today's emergency cabinet
meeting they understand stats about its
severity will be available before
christmas and will be used to help the
prime minister decide on restrictions
same story for the daily telegraph their
headline confusion at christmas
the guardian says that even though kovid
is surging the cabinet split means
there's there will be no new curbs at
least for now
the times says the delay in making any
decision is good news for hopes of a
normal christmas in the meantime as the
sun puts it hold on to your baubles
the daily mirror leads with news that
the queen will spend christmas at
windsor instead of sandringham
dominic robb's remarked that the people
photographed meeting in boris johnson's
garden last year weren't partying
because they were wearing suits is the
lead for the metro with the headline
rob's tailor-made excuse
so plenty to talk about peppa and harry
are here um well harry let's start with
your paper the sun hold on to your
baubles the pm warning of new covered
curbs at any moment
what's happening is it a case of case
not proven or is it paralysis which is
what the shadow health secretary said
yeah i mean it's
there was a drumbeat of of every health
uh figure you could possibly imagine
leaping to the airwaves all weekend
saying now is the time we must do
something quickly
and that that old playbook um sort of
crashing into political reality this
morning now
um you could call it paralysis and a
divided cabinet if you believe that the
prime minister is on the side of the
people who want to go further with the
restrictions but i suspect um that he's
probably not one of those people i think
politically i'm not sure he could
survive being the person that locks down
christmas at short notice two years in a
row and whether the public would even
listen uh on a wide scale to any any
sort of
any attempt to
uh to hamper with this christmas after
the pain of the last year and the
disaster that was last winter so the
cabinet obviously met today for two
hours the prime minister let everyone
around the table vent some spleen uh
finally he's been quite badly stung by
his close ally lord frost resigning who
cited covert very highly on the list of
reasons that he was out the door so i
think he wanted to let off some steam
let some pressure out and frankly let
perhaps some of his ministers do his
hard work which was resisting this wave
of noise from the from the health lobby
to to move to immediate restrictions now
that said i think the writing is pretty
clear on the wall tonight that um while
christmas might be fine i wouldn't be
making any new year's eve plans um
tonight we just we talked about this
this time about this time last week that
eventually there will probably be with
the soaring omicron cases a time ahead
of its peak that's expected in january
to perhaps
have some return to semi-restrictions
like the rule of six or perhaps
outdoor hospitality um but it does feel
tonight there's been a concerted effort
by both the prime minister
and some of his more sort of
freedom-loving cabinet ministers to kick
this the other side of the weekend yes i
mean we we get it i think he doesn't
want to be grinch again does he and who
would in many respects but let's take a
look at that political reality you
talked about there pippa a hundred mps
we know voted against plan b
uh has pippa frozen hold on a second
i think she might have done harry we're
going to try and reset your sound you're
slightly on the edge of dalek but we're
going to have to persist with you i'm
sorry we'll have to
we'll do one at a time um
this is the problem with suddenly
working from home full-time we're back
to
but back to your mute and uh 22 2020
tech problems um no but the prime
minister was stung as well as the
resignation of law frost by a hundred
strong rebellion
um last last week so there's no appetite
within the conservative party for
further restrictions this side of
christmas and the problem is is that
you've got the labour party he was
saying well we need to do something now
and um
it's a very easy attack for the for the
for the opposition to make which is well
actually the prime minister is putting
his party interests before
uh before the national interest so it's
going to be a bit of a vicious fight in
the coming days about that yes i think
pippa we've got you back um we were just
saying that the political reality for
the prime minister is the 100 mps who
voted against plan b the lord frost
resignation even to be fair perhaps
possibly cabinet members around the room
who are beginning to think about a
leadership challenge and i'm wondering
who might support them whichever way
they go so my question is will there
ever be given that a time when the prime
minister can
bring in
the sort of restrictions that some
scientists want him to
well his standing is certainly faltering
um within the conservative party and uh
not least as you say um
having lost lord frost one of his
closest and most supportive cabinet
ministers um ostensibly over the covered
restrictions but also i think
brexit may have played a part but we'll
come on to that we'll come on to that
later i'm sure um
i think the reality is is that without
that data which explicitly makes clear
the link between
hospitalizations and
high case numbers for omicron
he's going to struggle to get it through
um through with the support of his party
he could obviously rely on labor but
that's politically very difficult for
him
and he
and the problem is of course from a
scientist perspective that it's already
too late um that the data you know you
need to sort of go before the data
really shows
how severe it may be uh so it's it's
certainly problematic for him but i
think he's i think he's kind of have
strong actually i don't think he's going
to be able to do it and that's part of
what today's decision to delay making a
decision was about that he's not in a
position politically where he could push
through any more restrictions um not
least with um certainly at least without
exploding you know
his own party and i don't think that
well quite clearly he doesn't he doesn't
want to do that when he's already in
such a fragile position and and many of
the newspapers are leading on this
difficulty of making the decision the
fragile position you're talking about
you know right from uh the telegraph
talking about confusion uh right through
to the financial times johnson faces a
cabinet deadlock on covered curves
before christmas you know the guardian
two covered surges but cabinet split
means no extra curbs for now
um so this is the this is the great
difficulty isn't it harry uh about the
decision making uh we've got you back
hopefully without the garlic element of
it although you know we could still hear
you
garlic not garlic garlic yes
no just saying about the the ability to
make a decision uh is very difficult and
in the meantime you know her majesty the
queen in in pippa's paper has she's made
the decision um for whatever reason but
uh certainly she takes a sense of what
feels right for the nation
yes and again without being too
conspiratorial i will take the the
buckingham palace statement at their
word on that one um but you know the
idea of moving the entire royal
household at a time of heightened covert
restrictions given how carefully they
bubbled last year it seems a little bit
more sensible to stay at windsor
uh a little bit more straightforward um
look the advice with the government
tonight and i pushed them and pushed
them and pushed them on this everyone i
spoke to
from downing street to cabinet ministers
is are you telling people to change
their christmas plans and they said very
much saying no do not do not do not but
you can understand why there's a
lingering sense of
uh of fear tonight given that that's
exactly what they said last year and
then you know on the on the right at the
last minute when most people were
already cooking their christmas puddings
or were already on trains or driving
across the country they said well
actually no don't no no no actually
there is no christmas you know you've
got to you've got to go back you've got
to you've got to lock down again so
there's a there's a real sense of lack
of trust i think in in what the
government is saying uh which wasn't
really helped today i don't think by
this sort of void of
a few hours that sort of it also
disappeared into a sort of interesting
tory civil war rather than actually it
just felt like there was there was an
argument amongst themselves rather than
an argument about actually what is best
for the country
yes uh let's just see the mirror then uh
queen's quiet christmas her majesty
cancels plans amid national confusion
that word confusion back again and as i
said most of the other newspapers you
know the guardian the eye the telegraph
and so on talking about the cabinet
split uh covered surges no extra curbs
issue and many of the uh those mps who
had voted against plan b said they want
more data and i guess this was the the
message from cabinet too about
hospitalizations
about uh who is being admitted i think
pepper might have frozen again this is
very interesting isn't it she's still
there are you she can still hear us um
and the data that they want uh is about
how long people stay in hospital and
who's going in and why but do you think
actually given the rate of infection
amongst health service staff and other
emergency staff that's really the wrong
question and really it's about staff
losses to covid which will become the
most pertinent question uh most
pressingly
it's certainly both elements of it isn't
it
it's both elements and i think the
reality is for particularly hospitals
where we are tonight in london um which
are seeing large numbers of staff stuck
at home with carinova it's not
necessarily badly but nevertheless off
for 10 days um you know key workers that
are needed to support the nhs more
broadly let alone those uh er rising
cases of
patients who are ending up on the wards
um it's you know it's a huge problem
facing the nhs and that's something that
certainly that has been that has been
flagged by health leaders um you know
consistently over the last few days
they've said that the government needs
to make a decision sooner rather than
later and yet we still are here in the
state of limbo so it's a problem for the
nhs it's a problem for people and you
know there's been lots of conservative
adventures right across the party you
know different wings of it saying today
that the one thing that they want more
than anything is certainty because it
isn't just about whether you can spend
your christmas with your granny or you
know your friends from down the road
it's um it's about what happens after
that and there are people with weddings
planned with you know my email inbox i'm
sure harry is the same it's been full of
people emailing me saying i'm supposed
to be going on holiday on the 27th can i
go
i'm supposed to be getting a flight um i
you know i'm getting married i've
delayed it three times already is that
going to be able to go ahead i've got
this big new year's bash planned um all
this uncertainty about some quite you
know major events in people's lives and
they want to know whether it's going to
go ahead and uh you know the combination
of the the the
health experts and the public
are asking for more answers and those
answers just haven't been forthcoming
boris johnson's making it clear yes
christmas looks like it's going to go
ahead but he's going to reserve the
possibility of changes and as harry
hartley says that happened very suddenly
last year you compare that with nicolas
sturgeon who there's no actual
difference in position on the ground in
terms of whether christmas can go ahead
or not she just however made it clear
that there's no intention of last-minute
changes and i think that just that extra
little bit of of clarity
um gives people sort of maybe faith that
they can go ahead with their plans um at
least until you know boxing day and then
of course we'll have to wait and see
what happens after that yeah pippa crea
a social calendar agony aunt sounds like
you've got a post back full of it um but
just in terms of the cost without this
strong messaging the public behaviors
have already changed the telegraph
pointing out that the pubs and
restaurants christmas bill will be
enormously high like 1.5 billion that's
rent due on christmas eve
and yet their their income is obviously
falling away
yeah i thought it's really interesting
something that witty um
uh said to the cabinet not on this call
actually uh today but on saturday a
colleague of mine picked up this
particular gem that he said that
actually
um they've been pleasantly pleasantly
surprised by the number of people who
just changed their behavior overnight
when um the scientists and boris johnson
turned up the tv last week and and
basically scared everyone into
cancelling christmas parties and not
really going out now on from the health
lobby's point of view that's that is a
that is a win which he was very pleased
with that and actually if anything has
brought perhaps the prime minister a bit
of time before uh being able to have to
introduce restrictions because people
have already altered their behavior i
know i have already i've started to work
from home when i can and probably gone
out less than i have have done over
previous uh previous christmases but on
the flip side of that you've got the
economic impact of it and the problem is
is you've got
pubs and
pubs and hospitality and restaurants the
busiest time of year left being left
high and dry now uh the chancellor
jetted back from california in his very
unfortunately timed trip to um silicon
valley last week and he has been there
is something cooking there is something
coming for um for hospitality and
and it's going to be very needed not
necessarily this week but as you say
when rent starts to buy and in those
quieter weeks of january and february
and march traditionally times when
people don't go out less that's when
that this pain is really going to bite
the lag of the lack of funds from
christmas will really come home to roost
okay and i just worked out it's not
people working from home at this time of
night it's that last minute christmas
shopping online that the bandwidth or
whatever we call it these days is just
gone at the moment isn't it um so a
picture that that you did not put out
pippa it was the guardian originally uh
it's still in the front page of the
metro as well tonight too uh rob's
tailor-made excuse um we'll get on to
what he said uh earlier but but who has
a view like that who possibly leaked
this do you think
well there's quite interesting floor
path floor plans being sort of doing the
rounds of twitter and whatsapp groups of
number 10 over the last couple of days
and they seem to identify that uh it's
uh taken from the first floor of what is
it what effectively is number 11 used by
the um the chancellor's team however
they've been very quick to point out
that of course uh last summer this area
was cordoned off for
uh for basically in order to make the
building more
more covert compliant and more social
distancing it was a workspace that was
used for people right across the
building so you know despite the fact
that people at ed balls who of course
will know the view from that window very
well were mischievously tweeting out
tweeting um that he recognized we
recognized the view um i think that
they're distancing themselves from it
we've only got 10 seconds left question
for you very quickly then harry have
these photos been damaging for the prime
minister yes or no
absolutely and i think it was a
political enemy that's uh trying to get
them out there that's astonishing and
really brutal but if it's a civil
service mold then you know